the nightmare on elm street series is
one of horror's most enduring franchises
throughout the series a whole lot has
changed about this dream demon but some
things stay the same in the town of
springwood ohio here are some things
that happen in every nightmare on elm
street movie freddy leaves the trail of
destruction wherever he goes but no
matter how many people he slaughters he
can never seem to kill that final girl
the main hero of the nightmare on elm
street movies always gets away even when
it looked like he killed nancy in the
original film she showed up in dream
warriors very much alive granted the
final girl always has a tough time she
barely outmaneuvers freddie throughout
the story while he hacks and slashes her
friends and in the end just when it
seems like freddy is about to add the
final girl to his score she pulls the
rug out from under a big burned boy and
freddie's the one who ends up dead of
course sometimes the final girl in one
movie becomes a regular girl in a
subsequent movie at that point all bets
are off and freddie may very well
shuffle her off this mortal coil and we
should also point out that not all final
girls are actually girls in freddy's
revenge that role falls to jessie walsh
who's technically a final boy granted
his fate is left somewhat ambiguous at
the end of the film but we never see him
die and if nancy survived her bizarro
dream ending we're sure jesse is
probably fine
freddy always attacks his victims in
their dreams his victims occasionally
figure out how to pull him into the real
world but freddie begins stalking
potential human pin cushions in the
astral plane before it gets to that
point that's also one of the main
reasons why freddie makes such an
unsettling figure everyone has to sleep
and if freddy attacks and dreams where
he has absolute power then freddy can
kill anyone at any time any way he wants
to urgo every nightmare on elm street
film contains scenes of characters
drinking coffee munching down caffeine
pills blasting loud music directly into
their ear holes and engaging in various
other activities designed to avoid or
delay sleep it's a futile effort but the
cannon fodder kids and nightmare movies
all have to try
oddly enough the freddy movies depict
relationships between teenagers and
their adult guardians reasonably
accurately as anyone who remembers being
a teenager knows whenever teens find
themselves trapped in life or death
battles against demonic forces they
immediately learn that parents teachers
and professional mental health experts
are all completely useless making
matters worse grown-ups typically insist
the kids are simply stressed out and
need a nap these so-called responsible
people always claim the unholy menace
doesn't exist when in fact some of them
personally helped burn him alive after
the judge let him off on a technicality
nancy's dad provides an exception that
proves the rule in nightmare 3 dream
warriors when he tries to come through
for the gang at the westin hills
psychiatric center even then he was a
major skeptic in the first film and he
only decides to be useful after he
develops alcoholism due to freddie
killing nancy's mom in the real world if
a grown-up happens to be chronically
depressed and constantly drunk that
grown-up will be about as effective
against supernatural malevolence as a
bag of potatoes
for slasher fans there's a sadistic glee
in witnessing homicidal mayhem that
would traumatize us all into a coma if
we saw it happen in real life this is
extra true for nightmare devotees
because freddy kills any way he feels
like killing even if it defies the laws
of physics johnny depp made his big
screen debut as nancy's well-meaning
boyfriend in the original 1984 movie
freddy pulls glenn into what may be hell
then shoots his blood back up through
his mattress soaking the bedroom ceiling
in a geyser of crimson glen juice in
later films freddy's homicidal
tendencies take a turn for the goofy and
gimmicky there's a character who likes
comic books and nightmare 5 the dream
child so freddy physically sucks him
into a comic book and cuts him up while
he's two-dimensional there's a character
who smokes weed in freddy's dead so
freddie turns into a psychedelic
hallucination and kills him that way
sometimes he takes himself seriously but
other times freddy is basically willy
wonka except a troop of oompa loompas
don't appear to sing a judgmental song
after he destroys a young human life
one of the most disturbing things about
freddy is how he can morph and
manipulate his body whenever he feels
like it it's a staple of the series for
example freddy makes his arms grow
absurdly long right before he indulges
in his first on-screen taste of
slaughter in the second film he explodes
out of a young man's midsection then
heads across the room to stab another
hapless teen but freddie doesn't get
genuinely hyped about shape-shifting
until nightmare 3 dream warriors he
morphs his fingers into syringes to
murder a recovering addict becomes a big
old worm and he turns himself into a
television set before electrocuting a
mentally ill girl to death even in new
nightmare freddy puts gene simmons to
shame with his ever-growing tongue
stabbing and slashing might be freddie's
go-to choice for a quick and easy notch
on his belt but when it comes time to
kill someone in the weirdest manner
possible this slasher never hesitates to
change himself into some of the most
ridiculous stuff imaginable
one of the creepiest things about freddy
krueger is that he's got his own theme
song
and the frightening tune makes an
appearance in every film most of the
time it's a small group of little kids
singing it to keep time while they skip
rope since freddy's methods vary to wild
extremes depending on the
characteristics of his victim freddy
doesn't have a signature catch phrase
because no single pun or one-liner would
be effective for the majority of his
murdering but the wholesome image of
little kids skipping rope serves the
same purpose both on a visual and sonic
level as we know from many other films
little kids in horror movies are the
creepiest things ever all they have to
do is walk into a shot sing a spooky
song and it'll make you pee your pants
on the spot
there aren't a ton of constants that
stick throughout nightmare movies but if
you're a total psycho who genuinely
wants to see freddy krueger come out on
top then the experience of watching
these films must make for a profoundly
frustrating experience why because
freddy always loses freddy walks away
with his fair share of consolation
prices no doubt after his inevitable
vanquishing he might jump out of
seemingly nowhere and snatch up
someone's mom he might put his razor
hand through a young woman's torso or he
might wink at the camera as jason
voorhees carries his severed head off
screen he wins these sneaky after the
fact victories that mainly serve to
leave the door open for a possible
sequel but that's only after he comes up
short in whatever his primary goal
happened to be during the particular
story he can't win because one or more
of his prospective victims always
manages to outsmart and outmatch him but
if freddy krueger's purpose is to kill a
handful of people face defeat then
return in a couple of years when studio
executives decide it's time for another
movie maybe the concepts of winning and
losing don't concern him that much
perhaps freddy krueger is just a guy
with a job to do like the rest of us
the slasher subgenre frequently finds
itself accused of sameness and
redundancy and rightly so plenty of
slasher movies are exactly the same an
invincible monster is introduced and one
by one it cuts down a roster of
attractive 20-something actors playing
high schoolers a soul-surviving
protagonist vanquishes the adversary and
escapes and then the movie ends however
filmmakers started taking risks with
freddie as early as the first sequel a
nightmare on elm street 2 freddie's
revenge repurposes robert anglin's
signature villain into a metaphor for
repressed homosexuality the third movie
dream warriors takes place in a mental
asylum for troubled youths at one point
freddy turns into a giant worm version
of himself to eat a young patricia
arquette it's not as bold as freddy's
revenge but it's definitely shocking the
first three nightmare films are all
totally distinct from each other and the
following three movies are all too
ridiculous to be predictable freddy
turns his victims into a supernatural
pizza in nightmare on elm street 4 the
dream master that's not even scary it's
just bonkers things get especially wild
with new nightmare where director wes
craven turns the metatextual irony up to
11 by having kruger be an actual demon
that exists outside the nightmare movies
in other words freddy krueger doesn't
repeat himself his movies might not all
be great but at least he's never boring
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos but
your favorite horror films are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]